I mean, how much more degrading can you possibly be about being home?
This is a lifestyle many women choose,
and they absolutely love this lifestyle.
I absolutely love this lifestyle.
We don't think most of us have Plan b's.
Worst case scenario situations.
The fact is that everyone should have a Plan B
worst case scenario situation.
A woman who is also working and has a career,
if her husband dies
and they have a joint mortgage or something like that,
they would have to figure out a way to replace that income.
A lot of us have skills that are transferable to a job force.
It's not gonna be like business or CEO or like
those kinds of positions,
but it's not that we're incapable of taking
and providing for our families
if we had to.
And the thing is, is a lot of us have worked before staying home.
So we do have a resume.
Doesn't mean it's gonna be consistent and updated or like, whatever.
But again, there are transferable skills that one can have.
There's trades women.
That women can learn and work out of their home and do.
So it's not that we're helpless little doves.
Women who are traditional and stay home
would do the same exact thing
a woman who has a career and worked outside of the home would do.
And that is figure that crap out.
It's the worst case scenario for a lot of people,
and they figure it Out
and they move on with their lives
and they get help from people in their lives.
And that's why community is so important.
So yes, it is a lifestyle,
but just cause you don't value it doesn't make it less of a lifestyle.